sans surprise c'est bernard cazeneuve
qui remplace manuel valls 22e premier
ministre de la vème république et celui
qui restera le moins longtemps à l'hôtel
matignon
qu'est ce que vous voulez qu'il fasse
c'est déjà plié à passer la droite qui
est à paraître au livre des records car
ça sera le plus le premier ministre le
plus bref il remplace cresson cape et
d'épée 10 mois et loi s'approcha et
prend de moigny vous êtes un ami il est
un frère c'est rare en politique de
pouvoir compter et pouvoir s'appuyer sur
des hommes de qualité comme vous voir
que ce choix arrive un peu tard moi
j'aurais préféré que qu'il soit premier
ministre avant mais il a montré en
pratique qu'il était quelque part le
contraire de ce qu'a été manuel valls
ces derniers mois car je veux vous dire
mon indéfectible amitié mon profond
respect et ma très grande reconnaissance
pour la manière dont nous avons
travaillé ensemble au cours des derniers
mois et cela porte un nom dans la vie
politique et croyez-moi ça existe
l'amitié car protégé c'est la mission
que j'ai confié aussi à bernard
cazeneuve comme premier ministre mais
protégé ne suffit pas il faut préparer
l'avenir
je le connais bernard cazeneuve une de
ses phrases un jour profondément là il
m'a dit notre problème en politique
c'est qu'à gauche il dénonce à droite il
ya des fous et qu'à gauche il ya des
cons alors c'est un autre fidèle du
président qui prend sa place à
l'intérieur c'est une grande
responsabilité dans la période d'être le
ministre de l'intérieur et d'avoir
assuré avec le président de la
république avec le premier ministre la
protection
total des français c'est un gouvernement
sans ambition sans projet sans programme
donc ce sera le liquidateur du passif du
bilan de ce gouvernement sortant voir il
y a eu bien sûr des erreurs des échecs
ne vont pas atteint tous nos objectifs
mais nous avons contribué je crois
encore une fois à redresser le pays sur
l'économie sur l'industrie - c'est un
adversaire cabossée ils sont carbonisés
ils sont cramés ils sont les sortes de
laruns et j'invite les hommes de les
femmes de gauche de progrès les
républicains ceux qui ne veulent pas
d'ailleurs ni l'extrême droite ni du
programme très dur de françois fillon je
les invite évidemment à venir dans cette
primaire j'invite plutôt les
progressistes de gauche comme ceux du
centre de la droite à me rejoindre pour
faire en sorte qu' il n'y ait pas au
second tour une un simple choix entre le
front national et une droite
conservatrice
je dis à mes compatriotes n'ayez pas
peur et je dis aux candidats qui se
reconnaissent dans cette gauche qui
assume les responsabilités
n'ayez pas peur
qui